we are seeing a major shake-up in the
Democratic presidential battle ahead of
tomorrow's Super Tuesday vote former
mayor Pete Buddha judge dropped out
yesterday after a narrow delegate win in
Iowa and finishing second in New
Hampshire
Wouter judges you know was a long way
behind in Nevada and South Carolina Joe
Biden's decisive win in South Carolina
may have been a key factor in budda
judge's decision to leave the race the
former vice president sees himself as
the only candidate who can beat Bernie
Sanders who de jedge suggested he ended
his campaign to try to stop Sanders from
running away with the delegate lead as
Dean Reynolds reports his withdrawal was
almost as unexpected as his campaign
itself I told Pete to run because I knew
there were other kids sitting out there
in this country who needed to believe in
themselves - an emotional chastened
Giudice introduced his husband at a
final rally in South Bend Indiana where
the campaign started over ten months ago
and I am running for president of the 38
year old former Navy officer and one of
the youngest presidential candidates in
modern history rose to the top of a
crowded Democratic field with a moderate
platform
senator Sanders believes in an
inflexible ideological revolution that
leaves out most Democrats not to mention
most Americans Budaj edge won the most
number of Delegates in Iowa but has been
unable to build a broad coalition of
support particularly among black voters
something he addressed on CBS this
morning
back in December a lot of skepticism of
the new person showing up but I welcome
that challenge because it's critically
important not only to win but to deserve
to win nearly three months later he got
only three percent support from black
voters in South Carolina according to
CBS News exit polls supporters were
shocked by the news of his withdrawal
but say he'll be remembered for breaking
barriers didn't win the presidency but
he's up in the door
hopefully inspired all treated you
people to run profits CBS News political
contributor Joel Payne says this is just
the beginning for Budaj edge he is if
you just look generationally the
candidate best positioned over the next
decade plus to be a big player within a
Democratic Party now Payne also told us
that by withdrawing now Budaj has
probably pleased the Democratic Party
establishment which had been pressuring
him and other hopefuls to get out of the
race and let a single moderate candidate
solidify support Anthony Dean thank you